the republican
glenn younkin has won
in virginia
and the libs are not taking it well
i think we know the answer to some of
this i watched glenn younkin's
interviews on fox news and he did
nothing that claire he did not i mean he
worshipped at the altar of donald trump
on fox news he flew an insurrection flag
at his rallies he simply didn't he
played dumb about a a a zoom rally he
did not really put much distance between
himself and donald trump on the big lie
or the deadly insurrection in which
police officers were maimed by flagpole
so
i think that the the real ominous thing
is that
critical race theory
which isn't real
turned the suburbs
15 points
to the trump insurrection endorsed
republican what do democrats do about
that
so not a single thing that that woman
said there is true not a single thing
with one exception
critical race theory dot dot dot
turns the suburbs dot dot
15 points to the dot dot dot
republican i'm michael knowles the
micromoles show
[Music]
back to the show my favorite comment
yesterday is from eddie gesh who says
education is not supposed to be about
making people feel comfortable in school
it's about educating them yes this was
the the final campaign salvo from terry
mcauliffe the now vanquished former
governor of virginia and former future
governor of virginia terry mcauliffe
said we're going to fire white teachers
because black people don't feel
comfortable with white teachers which i
don't think is true to begin with but
second of all yes you're right education
is not about feeling comfortable or if
it is it's about comfort in the true
meaning of that word giving you strength
you know the idea of the bio tapestry
you got bishop odo smacking his own
retreating men with a club and it says
here bishop odo comforts the boys that's
yeah we got to give you strength and
sometimes
that is a little bit tough and we i
think we just taught a tough lesson to
democrats in virginia you know when you
want to protect
not just your state your country but
your identity i would recommend you
check out lifelock in the era of covid19
scams and hoaxes have really
proliferated haven't they including tech
support scams
which are surging to the top of the list
of internet scam threats they're
designed to trick you into believing
something is wrong and then they seek to
steal your personal information tap your
bank account or install dangerous
software on your device it's very
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats such as your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information they
will send you an alert
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock identity theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year by going to lifelock.com
knowlescanwlis that is
lifelock.com knowles k-n-w-l-e-s for 25
off
that woman from msnbc nicole wallace
she said that glenn younkin
he worshipped at the altar of trump
that's not true he tried to distance
himself as much as possible from trump
because he thought trump was going to
hurt him in the race he flew an
insurrection flag at his rally he didn't
what insert oh you oh she's referring to
the confederate flag i did glenya i
don't think glenn young can fluid oh
you're talking about the democrat
operative who we got on camera speaking
into a little microphone who
who wore a brand new printed and ironed
on confederate flag right in front of
the press
and who didn't get away with the stunt
okay so that that part wasn't true as
well who what what else did she say
about him that he
he played dumb about a tele rally oh
yeah donald trump supported uh glenn
young in the race but glenn young didn't
even show up to the tell a rally where
where donald trump called in
where he
glenn young supported a deadly
insurrection what dead oh you're talking
about the january 6th thing that wasn't
deadly that was a total lie from the new
york times and the washington post even
they had to admit it and by the way i
don't think glenn young even supported
the demonstration at the capitol and
critical race theory which doesn't exist
well i think it does exist i think
actually people on your own network have
admitted that it exists and you got to
get your story straight because half the
libs are saying crt doesn't exist half
the libs are saying that crt is awesome
and totally should be taught in schools
and is taught in schools so you got to
get your story straight here either way
crt
flipped the suburbs i think that last
part is probably fairly true of course
terry mcauliffe won't concede tara i was
up yesterday i woke up very early to do
my show yesterday in nashville
i then flew to florida to speak at the
national conservatism conference which
was terrific by the way
then i flew back here to nashville to do
an election live stream
and i did not want to go to bed
i thought look we won the race we
obviously won the race
i don't want to go to bed before they
declare victory
but freaking terry mcauliffe refused to
concede
well good evening everybody
[Applause]
what an honor to be here with you
tonight let me first of all thank you
for coming out here tonight and i i want
to thank our great governor ralph
northrup and pam northam
the great work that they have done
so we still got a lot of votes to count
we got about 18 of the vote out so we're
going to continue to count the votes
because every single virginian deserves
to have their vote
so terry mcauliffe is a crook i'm not
saying that every democrat politician is
equally corrupt or crooked but terry
mcauliffe really is crooked his closest
political allies are the clintons he's
just one of these slimy machine type
politicians and so terry mcauliffe was
hoping that if he could stall long
enough they could discover enough votes
in undisclosed boxes somewhere that just
happened to have terry mcauliffe's name
written on them and unfortunately for
him
the numbers were so strong for glenn
younkin that that would not work
there was an announcement from the from
the mcauliffe campaign the announcement
was that the the vote in fairfax county
was going to be delayed
the count oh they there was a problem
with the count they had to pause the
account we had flashbacks to 2020. oh
yeah you're gonna pause it until three
in the morning you're gonna find
truckloads full of ballots right and in
in mcauliffe's defense
it it is very difficult
to figure out how many ballots to stuff
into the ballot box uh before you know
what the numbers are in the other
counties so in his defense you know he
had to wait a little while it didn't
matter and by the way terry mcauliffe
never concedes okay don't don't forget
that terry mcauliffe
during this very campaign in the year of
our lord 2021
refused to admit that george w bush won
the 2000 presidential election
in this very campaign in the year of our
lord 2021
terry mcauliffe refused to acknowledge
that stacey abrams legitimately lost the
2018 uh georgia gubernatorial election
that's what happened so what did this
election come down to this election came
down to one
moment
that was repeated over and over
mcauliffe kept making the same mistake
the moment came
during
a uh
a question for mcauliffe on the quest on
the issue of education terry mcauliffe
said parents need to butt out
the parents had to write
to veto bills veto books glenn not to be
knowledge about it also take them off
the shelves and i'm not going to let
parents come into schools and actually
take votes out make their own decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents you've stopped the bill
that i don't think parents should be
telling schools what they should teach
but i don't think parents should be
telling schools what they should teach
now don't forget
education is not just about your reading
writing and arithmetic education broadly
is
how a child is raised right education is
not just about technical knowledge not
just about book learning it's about
moral knowledge it's about socialization
it's about how to be a citizen
and so if your kid is going to a school
for 12 years 13 years with kindergarten
now what 14 15 years with the pre-k now
what 16 17 18 19 years with college
which is being pushed for everybody or
more
then
what the terry mcauliffe is saying here
is you have no right to raise your kid
some government employee has the right
to raise your kid
but you do not have the right to raise
your kid i think
on this issue of education
the race came down to three things
it came down to chris ruffo chris ruffo
is the
scholar of the manhattan institute in
city journal who has been exposing
critical race theory and sort of setting
the stage for critical race theory
specifically and the kind of radical
racial and sexual ideologies being
taught in schools
i don't think this race would have
turned out the way it did without
chris ruffo doing that then there was
the next level and
you know i can say it without any pride
or false modesty because though this
involved friends of mine
it wasn't it wasn't me directly okay
it comes down to the sweet baby gang
okay and and my colleague matt walsh
going and pulling his stunt at the
school board in virginia
and exposing the radical it's not just
crt it's crt it's the crazy transgender
stuff it's the masking it's the making
the kids get the jab it's all of that
okay but it is kind of about the kids it
is kind of about the future and then
beyond that even more specifically
than chris or matt
it was this story
from luke rosiak the the daily wire
investigative journalist
a specific news story about a rape of a
young girl in a virginia school
that was covered up by that school
district because the school district
didn't want to have to answer for their
insane transgender bathroom policy
okay and that
that story to me is the pivotal story
because
all the rest is reacting to other things
that is that that were going on
the the rosiac story the the transgender
bathroom story
was a news story
that was not coming out
okay the new york times wasn't going to
cover it the washington post wasn't
going to cover it
and usually what happens because
investigative journalism is expensive is
the left-wing outlets
waste the money spend the money that
they're never going to make back
breaking the news and then conservative
outlets have to take their biased
accounts of those stories and then try
to parse that fact from fiction and so
we're always on the defensive and the
stories that they don't want to cover
they just don't get covered so the fact
that dw decided to invest in real
investigative journalism
i think played
a decisive role here there were other
things as well the covet lockdowns
people didn't like it
that went on and on and on the forest
vaccine mandates people didn't like it
the fact that gas is going through the
roof the fact that our grocery stores
are closed it i don't think it's simple
enough to say that the race was all
about education
but just as
the tea party was about taxes debt
government spending just as that was the
last even somewhat grassroots movement
on the right
so too this is the this is the latest
grassroots movement on the right that
i've seen
call it the crt party you know the tea
party was all about money and it was all
about
financial and fiscal issues this one is
about deeper issues cultural issues your
family who has the right to raise your
kids what the future of the country
looks like
when you want to protect your family by
the way i would strongly recommend you
check out ring this christmas season
deck the halls walls windows and doors
with the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm i am sure that
we all know about the ring video
doorbell by now i've been talking about
it for years and years and how
incredible it is and how it makes
everyone feel safe did you know that
ring makes an award-winning alarm ring
alarm is a powerful affordable home
security system that is so easy to
install even i can do it
gives you that same peace of mind that
same high-tech
technology that you get at the ring
video doorbell it brings it to every
corner of your house so this christmas
season
do it deck the halls the walls the doors
the windows every corner of your house
with the best deals of the year on the
award
winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on a ring
alarm security kit today this is
something that gives me peace of mind
especially when i'm traveling you know
i'm away from home it gives you peace of
mind when you're in your house when
you're at the office when you're on a
beach makes a wonderful gift ring.com
knowles so terry mcauliffe in virginia
ended his campaign
in a typically
shameful way he ended that campaign with
a lie about glenn younkin the
now governor-elect of virginia and
donald trump
mcauliffe uh says guess how glenn
younken is finishing this campaign he's
doing an event with donald trump here in
virginia where he brought
the hatred divisiveness that donald
trump brought to this country we're
going to put an end to donald trump's
future plans right here in virginia so
the mcauliffe campaign's strategy was to
make the race all about donald trump
kind of like what happened with the
recall in california
the young campaign strategy was to make
the race all about education and kids
both of them might have been fair
strategies donald trump is just not as
popular in virginia as he is say here in
the studios of the michael knowles show
you know if mcauliffe had tried that
strategy in the in the studios of the
michael knowles show it would have made
me much more likely to vote for glenn
younkin even than i already was but in
virginia you know trump didn't do as
well in virginia
what the reason i mention this
is is because it shows you
how how willing terry mcauliffe is to
lie not to bend the truth not to focus
on certain things to the exclusion of
others not to exaggerate but to lie
and the thing is
if you lie about the small things
you will lie about the big things too
and and that's
that's not a winning strategy here okay
because
when the left has a complete monopoly
over the media and the flow of
information
then you can get away with lies
but
when the right breaks a story when big
tech doesn't intervene to shut down that
story when the new when the truth gets
out you look like a jerk and you lose
your race
by the way the democrats did not did not
exactly hesitate to try to cheat here
there was a news report that came out
yesterday afternoon that virginia
polling precincts were turning away
maskless voters from casting their
ballots
so matt schlapp who's the head of the
american conservative union he said he
was rejected from voting he was turned
away from a polling place because he
wouldn't have his mask on this is
obviously a suppression of the
republican vote why because all the
people who don't wear masks are
republicans and all the sheep who do
wear the masks on the 593rd day of 15
days to slow the spread
are democrats and so if you say no you
have to wear a mask to
vote it'd be it'd be like the same as
saying you need to wear a terry
mccullough for governor shirt to vote
it's just a political symbol at this
point frankly i think it sort of always
was
so they were they were trying to
suppress the the election day turnout
democrats rigged the election
it ultimately didn't work but they
rigged the election by putting a huge
emphasis on early voting on mail-in
voting which all of which were downs to
the electoral benefit of democrats so
the election day voting was always going
to tilt heavily in republican favor so
if you can if you can suppress that
election day voting through the mask or
whatever other bogus reason you want
you're going to suppress the republican
vote thankfully
they got a rule the republicans got a
ruling that said you can't do that so
they sent a note out to all of the
reporters saying stay in line even if
you don't have a mask stay in line they
can't turn you away
and it obviously worked this was a big
crack
for the ruling class
okay i said this on the show yesterday i
said if
glenn younkin wins in virginia
it will
at least persuade republicans to some
degree that it's not a 100 rigged system
that actually it does still matter if
you go campaign if you go vote this is
going to have really important effects
in 2022 and 2024 and just for faith in
the country you know if if republicans
felt they got gypped
in in this election if they felt that
this was stolen
that would pose a big problem then you
would have
a great deal of the country thinking
that this is just a tin pot dictatorship
this is a banana republic where we can't
trust our elections anymore okay
there's a big crack for the ruling class
and you're seeing protests all around
and there's a difference between
the protests okay they're the protests
at the school boards with the parents
protesting crt and the gender stuff and
the vaccine mandates and all the rest of
it
and then there are
the
fake protests
there are the astroturf protests
the court jester protests that's what
you saw
at the big climate conference
with greta thundberg greta thundberg
began her career as a climate activist
when she was a teenager 15 16
she's now 18 so you're not hearing from
greta thundberg as much anymore because
the left is going to find some new child
to exploit it's not as interesting it
doesn't make as big a news story when
they're exploiting an 18 or 19 or 20
year old remember what happened to the
the gun kids remember the anti-gun kids
uh now i even forget the guy's name uh
david hogg david hogg right you don't
you don't hear from him anymore because
when he was a little kid a little kid he
was 16 17. when he was a minor the left
exploited him for their political
purposes now that he's in college he's
no use to them so he kind of goes away
so so greta thundberg showed up to the
climate conference and she gave her big
rousing protest
no more exploitation of people and
nature and the planets no more
exploitation no more blah blah blah
no matter whatever they're doing inside
them
[Applause]
so
what's strange people are talking about
how this was vulgar and how this was
incoherent and how this was a bad look
for the climate activists out there
to me this sounds just like all of the
other left wing protests
the blah blah blah blah blah blah that's
what they all sound like to me i'm like
a character in peanuts and the the
leftist protesters they are the teacher
just
so when they literally say that there's
really not much of a difference in terms
of what i
am hearing
but what what is interesting about this
to me
is not that the protest kind of fell
flat or that it's vulgar and the
vulgarity is really not a good look or
that it was incoherent because all they
were saying is blah blah blah it's that
the whole thing was fake the whole thing
is fake who who are greta thunberg and
her followers protesting
who are these leftist activists
protesting the leftists in the climate
conference for the leftist issue that
they all agree on
there's no there's no protest everybody
involved in this thing agrees
they all want to
harp on the climate issue they all want
to use the climate issue to take away
people's choices and way of life and
traditions
so it's just a
it's play acting
okay when parents show up to school
boards and say
you've taken too much power you're
teaching my kids a bunch of crap and
we're gonna kick you out and start
educating our own kids
that's a legitimate threat to the regime
when
environmentalists show up to the
environmentalist conference and say the
same things outside the conference that
the people inside the conference are
saying
that's that's not a threat that actually
bolsters the regime it's the appearance
of political opposition when in fact all
of them are on the same team during that
climate conference
joe biden
took a little bit of a nap
see
so you can see joe biden's looking at
some woman in front of him his eyes
though they're kind of they look a
little heavy
he's wearing his mask we're cutting off
a little bit of oxygen to the head what
little oxygen he was getting
you hear someone droning on in the
background there oh there they go
there go the eyes
just i'm just going to close them for
i'm just
just going to rest my eyes
huh
did someone's no come on joe
joe do you think anyone's noticing no
you can just rest your eyes for what
it'll be just a couple seconds
you can see his chest goes up
down
the sonorous melodious sounds this
climate just a couple minutes of sleep
people are attacking joe biden for this
they're making fun of him they're
criticizing him
especially on the right i think this is
unfair
no one criticizes biden more than i do
but i try to be fair about it i
completely defend joe biden here
any one of you listening right now
myself included anyone behind the
cameras here at the daily wire
we all would have fallen asleep during
that conference
you don't have to be old you don't have
to be senile you don't
that conference was absolute chloroform
through a microphone we all would have
fallen asleep i do not blame
joe biden what i do blame joe biden for
is
what he said at the conference joe biden
managed to rouse himself from his nap
long enough to apologize to the rest of
the world for america
and i i guess i shouldn't apologize but
i do apologize for the fact the united
states uh
the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put us sort of
behind
eight ball
uh the first thing i did when i liked it
i see my friend nadia said over there
because we talked about this before
while i was running oh we gotta i gotta
apologize i i don't wanna i shouldn't
apologize but i'm gonna apologize
because we pulled out of the paris
climate accord and not keeping up our
end of the bargain so first of all that
that just isn't true it's true we pulled
out of the paris climate accord but it's
not true that we therefore were
polluting the environment in this
incredible way and we weren't keeping up
with the other countries in that year
that we pulled out of the paris climate
accord
we led the world in carbon emissions i'm
not even saying that's a good thing or
something we should be bragging about
i'm just saying we did better
on the paris climate goals
than any of the countries that actually
remain signed onto the accord
they all just kind of lie they made a
big show about it they said that they
were really interested in cutting their
remissions and thought but they didn't
do it
we didn't say that we cared about that
at all but we actually did do it because
for the left what you say is much more
important than what you do
now
i'm much more interested in reality
i'm much less interested in the
fantasies and the narratives and the
spin from the left
and and all of these reasons why the
left-wing policies are supposed to be so
good and why theoretically they're so
good i care about
what's going on on the ground and the
fact is right now gas is going through
the roof which is why you should check
out get upside talk about good timing i
am thrilled to introduce an incredible
app that everyone who buys gas needs to
know about
get upside right now our listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles k w l e s and get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free use promo
code knowles canon wles to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank some people who drive a lot are
making as much as two to three hundred
dollars per month cash back there's no
catch the cash just gets added right to
your bank account or you can be paid
through paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands
download the free get upside app use
promo code nola's canon wlis get up to
50 cents per gallon back on your first
tank that is code
knowles also subscribe and start
listening now to the morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
marjorie taylor green you know marjorie
taylor green she's that
republican congressman
insurrectionist terrorist conspiracist
ist ist ism and ist
whom the democrats loathe they hate her
and a lot of squish republicans don't
like her either because she's a little
eccentric so they try to say i'm a
republican but i'm not that kind of
republican don't let me in with that
kind of republican i'm no i'm a good
kind i'm the good kind of republican
marjorie taylor greene
has racked up about 50 000
in fines for not wearing her mask
in the house of representatives
i love that nancy pelosi
decided she was going to impose a mask
mandate now don't forget the senate
which shares a building with the house
shares a very famous building the senate
does not have a mass mandate even though
the democrats control the senate too
so the the senators don't none of them
need to wear their masks
the house nancy pelosi has decided there
is a mask mandate
and so sensible people
are not following that
a lot of squishes are going along with
it
sensible people are ignoring it
and so pelosi's fining people
marge retailer green has racked up 50
g's in fines
i was actually talking to senator cruz
about this not so long ago and he said
that the mask mandate is actually pretty
useful because when you're walking
around at least the house side of things
you can instantly know who is a democrat
and who's a republican
among the staffers among anyone he's oh
wearing a mask that is a
democrat not wearing a mask that is a
republican
she's been documented marge retailer
green has been documented nearly two
dozen times
uh bucking the mandate
and uh
and she's showing no signs of stopping
i i really love this i really get a
great kick out of this it's it's
wonderful
i think the criticisms of marjorie
taylor green missed the point they will
say she said cookie things she said she
wrote something on facebook that's a
little weird she has had a colorful life
yeah uh-huh sure all of that's true
i think it misses the point
marge retailer green
is bucking the system
and if you want to buck the system
you have to be a little bit eccentric
okay
i'm not excusing everything the woman
said and done i don't really care
frankly
the eccentricity is sort of the point
because what usually happens is
you get some you get
democrats elected into the house don't
forget the house is about as low as it
gets in terms of
prominent national national political
roles okay they don't have a ton of
power they're
you've got to do a lot of team playing
in order to get any prominence
within the house whatsoever
so people get elected the democrats get
elected and what do they do they go
along with the system they are the
ruling class so that's not surprising
then some republicans get elected and
usually they just kind of go along to
get along
they know they've got to pay their dues
they've got to keep their heads down
maybe after a few terms maybe they can
start sponsoring legislation get on some
important committees get more of a
leadership role
and then you get the people who don't
want to go along to get along who
actually want to mix things up and
they've got to be a little bit eccentric
and they're going to rack up 50 000 in
fines they're going to post some weird
things on facebook
that's that's the cost of sending
someone to the congress
who is who is going to shake things up a
little bit fine by me i think it's well
worth the money you need tough
politicians all right we're seeing one i
was just in florida yesterday i think
i think that i haven't kept a real solid
count i have been to florida probably 15
times this year at least
i mean i've been to florida twice in the
last week
i haven't i might have been to florida
more than 15 times this year and it's
because all of the events are going on
in florida because florida opened up
very early because florida has good
republican leadership
in ron desantis
so ron desantis came out
and he
he was just speaking at a chamber of
commerce
and unfortunately we don't have video of
it but it is being reported in the
newspapers what he said very important
take a listen he said
if you are using your power as a
corporation and you are leveraging that
to try to advance any ideology i think
it's very dangerous for this country and
i'm not just gonna sit idly by
do you want to be more of a political
actor or more of a business actor
then he gives them
some political advice he says don't ever
think that caving to the mob is going to
save your bacon that's just going to
cause them to come back more absolutely
true
and then
though he kind of alluded to this in the
first part then he gets to his direct
threat he says you know if you do it
you are also going to come by some
people on the other side like me who are
not going to say well who are going to
say rather well wait a minute if you're
going to criticize what we're doing i
may criticize some of the things you are
doing i may look under the hood and not
like some things
i got a podium i got cameras that will
follow me around maybe i'll go talk
about that a little bit and so i think
it's something that's very damaging
yup
that's
that's it
the squish republican
the
republican talking points of a decade
ago the kind of more libertarian type
republican they would say oh
how dare you governor desantis you you
can't threaten private private
businesses the job creators the people
who have every right to push whatever
woke nonsense they can push abortion and
transgenderism and upend marriage and
crt they can push all of that's their
right as americans
they can sell out the country and all of
its traditions to china or wherever
that's their right that's free
enterprise
how dare you governor you have you're
just the person that the people elected
you have no right to do anything
you're just the person who the people
using the constitutional means available
to them came together to elect
to represent them in our government
you have no right to no i think you do
it right
i think we do have political rights in
this country and i think one of the big
mistakes of the last several decades is
that everyone privatized everything
they did the the left privatized all of
our social decisions
who you sleep with who you get to kill
as long as he's in the womb that sort of
thing
and the right
privatized all of our economic decisions
and therefore a lot of our political
decisions because if you say that
corporations can do whatever they they
want and we can never say peep about it
well then
you've given them the ability to push a
radical agenda you've given them the
ability to control speech you've given
them the ability to undermine our own
national interest for corporations on
the other side of the world
what what desantis is asserting here is
a deeply conservative principle we have
political rights and we can express them
through our duly elected representative
by the way what he says here people are
going to take issue they're going to say
if you push any ideology
we're going to do this to you and what
he's really implying is if you push a
leftist ideology
right if some corporation comes out and
is pro-life i don't think he's going to
take issue with them
they're going to say well he's being
disingenuous here no what he's saying is
literally true ideology
is a leftist phenomenon it is a
left-wing phenomenon of liberal
modernity
ideology
is
the i'll use a this is kind of a silly
definition or i mean it's a very good
definition but it sounds kind of flowery
and abstract
but oakshot calls ideology the
formalized abridgement of the supposed
substratum of rational truth contained
in the tradition to bring that down to
earth what that means is
it's a it's a five-point
rationalized manifesto it's saying hey
everything that matters in the entire
world between heaven and earth
everything in our whole society can be
boiled down to these three points
and as long as we do that then we're
gonna have a good time on earth and
that's just not true
life is complicated life is rich this is
why conservatives tend to reject
ideology for deeper more complex things
religion
tradition
local community
right this is why we're not so fast to
revolutionize the whole world
we say slow down hold on why are you
getting rid of that institution why are
you toppling that statue
why are you upending the social order
slow down or maybe don't do it
at all
that is a much more conservative
approach now one of the criticisms of
this in modernity is that ideologies are
really clear
they are marxism
libertarianism for that matter
all the narrow idea they're really clear
but as my friend father george rutler
points out shallows are clear shallow
thinking is clear
deep things are a little more murky
they're a little they're a little more
complex they're a little more profound
speaking of ideology
elon musk the eccentric billionaire
has decided he's going to found a
university
he's at least thinking about it elon
musk tweeted out a couple of days ago
am thinking of starting a new university
texas institute of technology and
science
and my my first reaction to this was
well that's good we should start our own
universities we should build up our own
institutions and uh it's good to make
sure we have tech and science but really
we should go further we need to focus on
the humanities and we need to focus on
the you know the english and history and
all of these things that really matter
to preserving our culture and this is
something that conservatives have
ignored for too long and then i realized
wait a second i think he's just making a
boob joke
because i if you look the texas
usually you'd say science and technology
right that's what you hear in a lot of
these schools so but it's not texas
institute of science it's texas
institute
of technology
and science
i think i think it might just be a boob
joke but it's an important lesson
nonetheless
and it reminds us that sometimes even in
jokes with a little bit of humor we can
make a very important
political point we should i hope elon
does do that and i hope he keeps the
name speaking of universities though
very sad news from a catholic university
loyola marymount you know i've spoken at
loyola marymount
very left-wing
place i spoke there with drew clavin a
few years ago
loyola marymount university is hosting a
fundraiser for planned parenthood
so
there's this group on campus lmu women
in politics and they're hosting a
fundraiser for planned parenthood and
now there is a petition being sent out
from a more conservative group
renew lmu that is requesting that the
fundraiser be cancelled
this is this is an important story
you're not going to hear about this
story in a lot of places it seems like
just kind of a minor issue on some
random campus somewhere
this is a very important story because
in this case it's a left-wing group that
is trying to bring people to campus
and it's the right wing group that's
trying to cancel those people from
coming to campus
and in recent years and i've i've been
i guess one of the
one of the main figures in this me and
ben and
candace and and other people where we
are brought to campuses to speak we as
conservatives and the left-wing campus
tries to cancel us and then everyone
decries cancel culture
now if you've been listening to this
show
or have read my recent book speechless
you'll know that
i don't decry cancel culture exactly i
think cancer culture has a lot of good
uses this would be one of them
okay i think we all understand that
an abortion factory has no role on a
catholic campus it is in direct
contradiction of catholic
teaching it's in direct contradiction of
uh
all that is good and true and beautiful
right they're just trying to kill a
bunch of babies
the students have no right to bring this
group to campus
and so they should be canceled but the
people who get hung up on this kind of
libertarian let's cancel cancel culture
kind of talk they
don't have a coherent way of of
addressing that
okay so i think we've got to we've got
to change the way we're talking about
cancel culture and recognize no some
things are true and some things are
false and we should exclude the things
that are false and we can settle it and
we can cancel people and if we're going
to cancel anyone it should be planned
parenthood it's not just that planned
parenthood should be canceled from the
campus planned parenthood should be
canceled period and the people who work
at planned parenthood should be
anathematized
and we should pass laws against this
kind of stuff and anyone who violates
those laws should go to jail at the very
least they should go to jail for a very
long time
okay that's cancel culture to the
furthest extreme it can be and it's a
very good thing
and we need to grow a little spine and
maybe a few other anatomical features
and be willing and confident to say
those sorts of things
speaking of the catholics
really unfortunate news from the supreme
court
a catholic hospital
has just been at the center of a of a
case that's going all the way up to the
supreme court
the case has to do with whether or not a
catholic hospital
can be forced to perform
a transgender surgery against its
conscience and frankly against the most
basic elements of
medical ethics
what happened here is a woman showed up
to a catholic hospital and said i want
you to perform a hysterectomy
i want you to remove my lady parts
because i think that i'm a man
and the catholic hospital said well
you're not a man
and
this is in violation of our faith and of
medical ethics so we're not going to do
that goes up to the court
the court the supreme court refuses to
hear the case
meaning they're going to uphold a lower
court's opinion and they're going to
they're going to establish the principle
at least that the catholic hospital must
perform this surgery
how's this possible we have a 63
conservative majority here
well it's possible because the
conservatives on the court thomas alito
gorsuch of course it's just a little
squishier but thomas alito and gorsuch
all three of them
sided with the catholic hospital at
least to hear the case
but the squishes
kavanaugh
roberts
and amy barrett
they
sided with the court's liberals and they
won't hear the case amy barrett
amy we fought so hard to get amy coney
barrett on the court i was going to be
the big win remember that and amy coney
barrett is a disaster she's a disaster
she's
not only gosh
the court should have gone so much
further here but they couldn't even give
us the bare minimum
to stop
radical activists from forcing
catholic hospitals to sterilize women
gosh
this this big court case over the
transgender surgery the court case that
wasn't because the supreme court
wouldn't even hear it and the courts
alleged a lot of the courts alleged
conservatives
sided with the liberals here
this shows you a big problem with the
conservative legal movement first of all
not only should catholic hospitals not
be forced to perform a transgender
surgery transgender surgery should be
illegal
okay there are three there are three
positions here right there's the leftist
position which is
we should promote transgender surgery
frankly we should trans the kids right
that's the left-wing position then
there's the squish libertarian position
which is if you want transgender surgery
that's fine if you're a woman who wants
to cut out her or a man who wants to cut
off his perfectly healthy organs to
indulge in some delusion that's totally
fine that's that's a good thing
do whatever you want just don't make me
pay for it do whatever you want just
don't just don't force anyone else to
and then there's the conservative
position which is no we it is wrong it
is not compassionate it's deeply cruel
and unjust
to
indulge the delusions of sick people who
believe that
they are really women when they're
actually men or vice versa and who are
mutilating their bodies there's nothing
right or good about that there's no
there's no political right to do that
and we shouldn't do it
it's a violation of medical ethics at
first
do no harm
but we can't forget about that
conversation
we can't even now say that you can't
force a catholic hospital to do it
what this is showing is that the
conservative legal movement is a joke
it's a joke
how many times
if we push to get the conservative on
the court and then the conservative
when push comes to shove buckles it's a
joke and it's too bad because we built
up these institutions in the
conservative legal movement federal
society things like that and it hasn't
worked it hasn't worked out
we have lost almost every important
court case some of which are
society defining court cases
the radical new definition of marriage
things like that
we've lost them almost all of them
we need a new conservative legal
movement
some people are working on this adrian
vermeuel at harvard is working on this
josh hammer my friend who i saw
yesterday at the national conservative
conference is working on this
status quo isn't working and we should
not
we're like we're like charlie brown with
the football we just we think the next
time lucy's going to hold the football
in place lucy is not going to hold the
football in place okay now
there is another big case coming up
where i hope barrett can redeem herself
but i'm not sure i'm necessarily holding
my breath
this is an abortion case
it's going to be the biggest court case
in a very long time
that could overturn roe v wade and
planned parenthood v casey
but you look at you look at at the
record here for someone like a kavanaugh
or someone like a barrett certainly
someone like roberts you really think
they're going to overturn roe v wade you
really think they have the
integrity and the courage to do that
i it doesn't seem like that to me i hope
they prove me wrong i hope they proved
me wrong meanwhile the abortion
advocates are getting more brazen
there
there was a
new law that's just come up through
illinois
that will repeal an abortion parental
notification law so the upshot of this
is that
minors will be able to
kill their babies through abortion
without the parents ever finding out and
all these perverts and sickos in the
democrat democratic party in illinois
including the governor
are
thrilled about it they couldn't be
happier
terribly sad stuff obviously terribly
sad for the babies and for the girls and
for everyone involved
it does bring up this political question
though that we keep coming back to
it's the political question that defines
the elections that we've just had
which is the basic unit of society so i
said that the question that mattered in
in virginia is who gets to raise your
kids some government employee or you
well that question is actually just part
of an of an even more basic question
what is the basic unit of society
the individual
or
the family
and this isn't i told you there are
these three groups in society there's
the leftists there's the kind of
libertarian squish types then they're
the conservatives
and very often it's the conservatives
and the libertarians who are on the same
side fighting against the leftists but
on this quest on this most basic
political question it's the opposite
it's the leftists and the libertarians
fighting against the conservatives
what is the most basic element of
society
the leftists
and the libertarians
would probably say the individual
i'm i'm simplifying a little bit but i
think that that's basically the answer
they would say the individual
the individual is the basic unit of
society the entire purpose of government
is to protect individual rights
don't tread on me the individual forget
me the political community just me the
individual
and so
if the individual is the basic unit of
society
you can see
the logic or the illogic behind a law
like this in illinois
it's the individual the end of if the
individual if if there is a right to an
abortion then the individual has that
right it's not about the family deciding
now the conservatives believe that the
individual is actually not the basic
unit of society that it's the family
right if the individual is the basic
unit of the society then the state has a
as a claim
to the education of the child
as a has the primary claim to the
education of the child
right because it's maybe maybe the kid's
got a bad family and the state needs to
come in and protect that kid from all
the craziness that the family's gonna
fill his head with you know craziness
about like um
religion and civics and love of country
and morality and all that
but if the family is the basic unit of
society
then before the state can intervene
the state needs to deal with the family
first
and if there is a right to an abortion
before the
kid can get the abortion the kid needs
to talk to the family first
this seems
you go from this very specific issue in
virginia this issue of the rape and the
school or this issue of critical race
theory in the classroom to this much
more abstract question what's the basic
unit of society
but that is really what we are debating
here and
having just come from the national
conservatism conference yesterday it
seems to me pretty clear
that we're moving in a more conservative
direction that the right is waking up
and saying wait a second if we just keep
prattling on about individual individual
individual we're going to end up exactly
where the leftists did
we need to defend those institutions
that will actually protect us against
the state if we're all just atomized
individuals the state's going to clobber
us we need to protect those institutions
that actually defend us the family the
local community
the
state against the federal government
that's what we've got to protect that's
what just won in virginia
we'll see if we can take that into 2022
and 2024 and further on out i'm michael
moses the michael nolan see
[Music]
tomorrow michael knowles show is
produced by ben davies executive
producer jeremy bori our technical
director is austin stevens supervising
producer mathis glover production
manager pavel vadofsky editor and
associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 21. on the matte wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show